we are going back to the phones at 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 50 let's check in with Jeremy
in Wisconsin Jeremy in Wisconsin on the
608 number Jeremy what's going on hey
David how are you doing good how are you
okay so my question sort of relates to I
guess the ever-increasing role of
international bodies and governance so
seeing I guess the example I'm thinking
about is the Amazon rainforest how that
obviously if it's been destruct or it's
being destroyed it has international
consequences that affect every nation so
I was wondering if you think with things
like that going on and kind of
globalization increasing in general do
you think international bodies will be
more strong in the future and do you
think they should go in that route well
I've said before that the the idea that
most of our major issues can be solved
within country borders is increasingly
an idea of the past I mean listen the US
can solve campaign finance internally
sure but the u.s. is not going to be
able to deal with automation and
outsourcing independently we're not
going to be able to deal with climate
change independently we're not going to
be able to deal with pollution
independently space travel is something
that is going to exceed country lines
its space exploration so the the hyper
nationalist mentality that other
people's problems are only theirs and
not ours and all of our problems are
merely ours to solve and we don't need
anybody else it is such an antiquated
and-and-and-and but at this point
frankly bogus assertion that we are
going to need to solve these issues
together that's why that's another
reason aside from sometimes the
xenophobic overtones of the hyper
nationalists it also just doesn't work
that's fair yeah so I was wondering I
guess you see the I guess the results of
the European model how there's been a
little bit of pushback to that with the
rise of I guess nationalist rhetoric in
parts of the world do you think America
is going to go down the European model
and you're going to see more I guess
global connections in terms of making
policy if we if we elect the right
people sure I mean the curve
president to someone who has resisted
that and is more of a go it go it alone
sort of guy and the effect that it's
having is that increasingly the United
States doesn't have a seat at the adult
table on more and more issues when it
comes to a global trade Trump is just
putting tariffs on people and
increasingly the the the sort of
outcasts when it comes to climate change
he's not even invited to a lot of
important summits and discussions so I I
hope that that happens but it's going to
depend on who we elect awesome all right
thank you David appreciate you answering
my question all right Jeremy great to
hear from you